okay uh this this story is a headache
um and there's just so much to talk
about so let's
let's do it in detail and kind of do it
justice
donald trump surfaced from the hole in
which he's been hiding for weeks
yesterday
to deliver a four-minute speech about
the coveted relief package which we
deeply criticized yesterday for its many
flaws and its cronyistic
elements and the i would say there's a
two-sided coin to donald trump's
four-minute speech
there's things i he said i agree with
and things that he said that i disagree
with
but it's actually much worse than that
it's like a four-sided coin
that you would be using on a chessboard
while playing 4d chess i i
did i don't have a metaphor to really
explain
the erratic and confused nature of what
donald trump said yesterday so rather
than tell you
in advance let's just start going
through it some aspects of this
four-minute statement are completely
deranged
and at the same time donald trump
correctly said six hundred dollars per
person is not enough
i would like to see two thousand dollars
per person that's great
but this was still a wacky lie riddled
fiasco
so let's go through it all you will also
notice donald trump doesn't look or
sound good
slurring a lot that thing where he's
tripping over his tongue almost like his
teeth are too big or his tongue's
getting in the way worse than we saw
before the election so let's just jump
right into it we're gonna look at the
full four minutes
throughout the summer democrats cruelly
blocked covet relief legislation
in an effort to advance their extreme
left-wing agenda
and influence the election so this is
already a lie i mean
democrats proposed more relief months
ago before the summer
mitch mcconnell said we're not doing
another relief bill
trump was m.i.a every once in a while
saying well
there's negotiation uh so so that's just
an absolute lie democrats
almost immediately after the first bill
were proposing even including two
thousand dollars per month per month
like our friend ro khanna let's continue
then a few months ago
congress started negotiations on a new
package to get
urgently needed help to the american
people
it's taken forever however the bill they
are now planning to send back to my desk
is much different than anticipated
it really is a disgrace for example
among the more than
five thousand pages in this bill which
nobody in congress has read because of
its length and complexity
it's called the coveted relief bill but
it has almost
nothing to do with covet okay now trump
is correct uh the bill is outrageously
long
members of congress didn't have time to
read it and tons of it has nothing to do
with covid
but it's not that the covet bill has
nothing to do with covid remember
they wrapped up together a
funding of government bill and the
coveted bill
5 500 pages and were given everything to
vote on together so
trump trump is right that not there
wasn't enough time
but he's now starting to get into one of
the big deceptions of the speech let's
continue
this bill contains 85.5 million dollars
for assistance to
cambodia 134 million dollars to burma
1.3 billion dollars for egypt
and the egyptian military which will go
out and buy almost exclusively
russian military equipment 25 million
dollars for
democracy and gender programs in
pakistan
505 million dollars to belize costa rica
el salvador guatemala
honduras nicaragua and panama
40 million dollars for the kennedy
center in washington dc
which is not even open for business 1
billion
for the smithsonian and an additional
154 million dollars
for the national gallery of art
likewise these facilities are
essentially
not open seven million dollars for reef
fish
management 25 billion dollars to combat
asian carp 2.5 million dollars to count
the number of amberjack fish
in the gulf of mexico a provision to
promote
the breeding of fish in federal
hatcheries
three million dollars in poultry
production technology
two million dollars to research the
impact of downed trees
566 million dollars for construction
projects
at the fbi okay so so this this is
this is now where it goes completely off
the rails
um first of all trump only mentions
countries he doesn't care for or or sort
of like
s-hole countries countries he doesn't
think we should give money to
and he mentions climate and environment
related stuff that he also
doesn't care for and and i want to be
careful because this is two-sided
none of that stuff is part of the covid
bill remember
they had two bills together this was
like an omnibus you had the funding of
government and you had covid
and in the funding of government you
have aid and money designated for
different countries now
it's not really the covet bill does
trump know that
i don't know the answer to that there
are lots of people who
fell for the idea that a lot of these
things are in the covid bill when
they're not
trump could be lying in order to
make a political point or i don't know
but trump himself may not real like
trump may just be watching news max fox
whatever
and he may be falling for the idea that
the funding
is in the covet bill um
i i don't know i really don't know the
answer now
in fairness overall
when you look at the totality of what's
going on here uh
donald trump is simultaneously
stumbling across some important
critiques of the system like
trump doesn't this is it's so insane if
trump
instead of just saying we're giving
money to pakistan and for carp
or whatever if he were to say and and
and sort of say also mentioning
5500 pages they didn't have time to look
at it if instead
he said these two bills shouldn't even
be together
the coveted bill should be simple it
should be a standalone bill
it should have been shorter people
should have been able to it should have
been short enough that everybody can
actually look at it and then separately
deal with this other bill
that would be a really good critique of
how politics is done
instead trump goes almost into his
xenophobic stuff of listing countries we
shouldn't be giving money to
and then he builds on that by going into
the immigration stuff
the bill also allows stimulus checks for
the family members of illegal aliens
allowing them to get up to one thousand
eight hundred dollars each
this is far more than the americans are
given
now this is really deceptive
trump's claim is that americans get
six hundred dollars but illegal
immigrants get eighteen hundred dollars
that's just not true okay and and let's
see if i can explain this
what is true is that if you are a us
citizen
or a legal permanent resident with a
green card you get six hundred dollars
and you get the six hundred dollars even
if your spouse or partner
is here illegally okay the spouse or
partner doesn't get 600
undocumented immigrants don't get any
money you
don't lose your 600 if your
spouse or partner is an undocumented
immigrant and
if you are here legally and you have
kids here
you get the six hundred dollars per kid
even if your spouse or partner
uh is an undocumented immigrant so so
trump saying
illegal immigrants get more money than
americans
is wrong in a bunch of different ways
the point is
being with an undocumented immigrant
does not preclude
you as a legal citizen or resident from
getting six hundred dollars for yourself
or the six hundred dollars per child
it's a completely
fabricated way to attack immigrants
let's continue despite all of this
wasteful spending
and much more the 900 billion dollar
package provides hard-working taxpayers
with only six hundred dollars each in
relief payments
and not enough money is given to small
businesses
and in particular restaurants whose
owners have suffered so grievously
they were only given a deduction
for others to use in business
their restaurant for two years this
two-year period must be withdrawn
which will allow the owners to obtain
financing
and get their restaurants back in
condition
congress can terminate it at a much
later date but two years is not
acceptable it's not enough
now this is where i find trump to be
saying some things correctly and this
is why the populist rhetoric can be so
tricky and so pernicious
trump is saying six hundred dollars
isn't enough
and there isn't enough for small
businesses like restaurants
i agree that's correct but it's all
wrapped up in lies
and xenophobia but on that point i agree
and donald trump actually makes a couple
more good points
congress found plenty of money for
foreign countries lobbyists and special
interests
while sending the bare minimum to the
american people
who need it it wasn't their fault it was
china's fault not their fault i am
asking congress to amend this bill and
increase the ridiculously low
six hundred dollars to two thousand
dollars
or four thousand dollars for a couple
i'm also asking congress to immediately
get rid of the wasteful and unnecessary
items
from this legislation so trump wants two
thousand dollars
not six hundred dollars that number
happens to be
exactly what people like ro khanna
congressmen
have been asking for for months
including when trump claimed
oh democrats didn't negotiate he said
that at the very start of the speech
this is all backwards and along those
lines
trump now complaining about all these
countries getting money egypt etc
trump asked for those countries to get
money in his
budget but now he's saying the problem
is they're getting the money in the
covid bill
which they're really not they're getting
it in the bill that was voted on
in in conjunction with the coveted bill
so
it's all lies and then now trump on the
number of dollars
per person happens to pick the exact
number that many democrats were asking
for two thousand dollars and immediately
many democrats jumping and saying great
let we'll rewrite it right now and put
in two thousand dollars
that it doesn't republicans don't want
that but we're glad to do that so
trump is right on some aspects here but
he's a liar
and he's completely disingenuous and
then now the rap with donald trump
threatening to veto and he just can't
help himself he has to throw in
maybe he will actually be the person
sworn in this january 20th and not joe
biden
and to send me a suitable bill or else
the next administration will have to
deliver a coveted relief package
and maybe that administration will be me
and we will get it done thank you very
much
he cannot help himself he at
any event no matter what it's about he
has to say
it might be me who gets that second term
on january 20th not joe biden so
the big picture is uh if trump does veto
it
nobody gets a penny and that's the risk
right now
uh let's call trump's bluff trump says
he wants two grand
rewrite the bill democrats say you want
to do the two grand
and put it on republicans to say no
if trump really is serious about he
wants two grand per person
democrats are ready to do it and make it
be mitch mcconnell
or whoever is going to come out and say
no no no no we don't want to do the two
grand so
we'll see what the next 24 hours bring
if this ends up getting people 2 000
instead of 600
even as disingenuous and dishonest and
clueless as trump is
i'll be i'll be glad and remember i'm
getting zero i'm not negotiating for
myself i'm not getting any
money from this um but remember there
were two bills here
funding government and covid and uh if
it's vetoed
not only do people get nothing we may
even end up with another government
shutdown
who knows what happens then in terms of
transition
in terms of so many different things uh
but we'll
we'll deal with that if and when it
becomes an issue remember
that on january 1 2021 we have a one day
membership special going on if you've
been thinking of grabbing a membership
at jointpakman.com
but you want a completely disgusting
immoral discount with which to do it
uh 1121 is the day if you want to be
notified of this great membership
special just
get on our newsletter you can sign up at
davidpakman.com
and january 1st you will get a perfect
email from me telling you exactly how to
sign
up if you are anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video